congressman Matt Gaetz of Florida is a
lawmaker pushing to do that to change
section 230 we're grateful for that he
joins us tonight congressman thanks so
much for coming on so why hasn't this
happened already they're violating the
intent of the law big tech buys off
Congress so as to maintain special
privileges that local newspapers and
television stations don't enjoy that's
why the president's executive order
today is one very important next step
because if we just wait around big tech
will steal this election from Donald
Trump and from the American people in
2016 we won three Rust Belt states by a
point each and that was when nobody
thought Donald Trump could win in 2020
we've lost the element of surprise and
so we have to be as aggressive as they
are
that means bills like Senator Holly and
I have I have filed to change section
230 so as to out these entities as
publishers and not the unbiased
platforms they are it means an executive
order like the president has issued but
it also means getting the other elements
of government to enforce existing law
the Federal Election Commission needs to
get off their Duff twitter is
interfering with an election I heard
Democrats say for three years that
Russia was interfering with an election
that was a hoax
we have domestic election interference
going on right now I'll be filing a
complaint with the Federal Election
Commission tomorrow because of what they
have done to President Trump and as a
voter I have the standing to do it and
president Trump should call for a
decision on the Federal Election
Commission questions that are before
them so that these tech companies get
flushed out of the bushes look Mark
Zuckerberg argues and in this I agree
with him that you don't want to see
section 230 or vote you you want people
to have liability from libel suits
because then you can have much more
information a free flow of information
so what do you do so you probably don't
want to change that but you have to make
these companies live up to the promise
they made to be neutral platforms how do
you force them to do that how should
Congress do that and again why haven't
they well again again big tech companies
have a tremendous amount of influence
over Congress it's one reason why I
don't take their PAC money or anyone
elses federal PAC money but on the
question of what has to be done I agree
with you but if someone is going to a
that they are a non-biased neutral
platform we should not just take that as
an article of faith we actually have to
have investigative work done
transparency disclosures if we're gonna
give these folks the privileges that you
would give a you public utility company
maybe we need to start regulating tech
like the public utilities as they are
that's exactly that's it I you know I
hate to think it's gonna come down but I
think it's gonna have to they have too
much power congressman thanks so much
for that good to see you thank you